um you guys I feel like obviously Andrew
I think I I credited him to changing how
people consume comedy
how they think of comedy and I think um
kind of the Innovation you know I think
when we go through something like covid
right yeah it kind of forces you to
change your approach to whatever your um
livelihood is yes yeah and I I just
think back to the like turn your phone
this way brilliant and how it just kind
of changed just you know the way people
and I know Louis CK was releasing
specials on his own but just like on the
YouTube side like I can't really think
of anybody doing the YouTube so I know
in India they were doing a lot of Comedy
clips online because that was the only
way they could do stand up right get it
out there but Andrew was the first guy
in America which is kind of where
everybody's looking for right The
Guiding Light of stand up to be like yo
nobody's buying the special I'm just
going to put it out online and if it
wasn't for that I wouldn't not only
because he's done so much for me but
like I wouldn't be able to sell any
tickets on my own because now I'm
selling tickets through just stand-up
Clips because I saw that model so I'm
like oh and now you're scrolling through
IG it's nauseating how much stand-up
there is it is very nauseating for sure
because I follow a lot of comedians like
[ __ ] everybody's got a [ __ ] even some
of these guys are just not funny it's
they absolutely should do it you gotta
do it right sometimes I'll see the crowd
work stuff and I'll be like
yeah the crowd yeah it's rough it's
rough luckily we were forged in the
comedy club where we came up wasn't even
a comedy club it was called the Village
Lantern is a bar upstairs and then
downstairs in the basement there was
nobody there and they would just let us
do stand-up we would get people off the
street bring them down if you had five
people you could do a show oh that's
dope so but five people I can't do my
bits for five people right you gotta
interact you gotta interact with those
people yeah it was like there's even
three people sometimes they'd be looking
at me like are you [ __ ] oh you is
this are you a human being dude so you
had to learn to talk to them you had to
learn to interact you had to get your
crowd Work Sharp so we had years of that
before we started dropping Clips with
crowd work